Y esta es la primera vez que desde los
atentados del 11 de septiembre todos los
aviones en Estados Unidos se tuvieron
que quedar en el suelo no pudieron
despegar ni aterrizar inicialmente los
problemas empezaron a las 8:30 de anoche
hora del este de Estados Unidos y justo
después de las nueve de la mañana hora
del este de Estados Unidos pues las
operaciones aéreas de este país
regresaron a la normalidad el
departamento de transporte
subsecretario y el senado también el
presidente han dicho que pues ya se
empezará una investigación para aclares
para conocer Cuáles fueron los detalles
de estos problemas que llevaron a más de
4.300 vuelos atrasados en todo el
territorio estadounidense y que se sabe
de qué ha dicho la Casa Blanca sobre
Cuáles son los efectos
Exactamente La Casa Blanca pues se va a
pronunciar al respecto hoy a las dos de
la tarde en su rueda de prensa la jefe
de prensa va a estar allá tratando de
esclarecer y dar más detalles de lo
ocurrido ustedes lo mencionaban el
congreso también pues va a empezar una
investigación paralela además de el
departamento de transporte y pues hay
que tener en cuenta que bailen ya está
al tanto de la situación que durante
toda la mañana pues ha sido informado de
la situación y obviamente pues también
está informado de que ya los vuelos
empiezan a operar con normalidad a pesar
de estos retrasos